i'd say season three you can hardly
catch your breath so i wasn't expecting
our show to be so merciless the keys
they can bring about the greatest good
or the darkest evil and you as the maker
get to decide
season two of lock and key was even
better than i was hoping for we are
going to discuss spoilers do you
understand
good connor i want to start with you
because tyler had one hell of a season
in lock and key season two i want to
talk about your very final scene tyler
decides to leave the magic of key house
behind and go off on an adventure and
kind of heal and have a normal life what
was your reaction when you learned of
his decision it's gonna sound weird to
say about a choice that a character i'm
playing made but i was proud of him
tyler has been through a lot not just in
season two but in season one i mean he
lost his dad he moved across the country
he discovered that magic exists he
fought
demons he
and then at the end of season two he
loses his
you know the person he's in love with
and not just loses but he's involved in
it in a way that he finds difficult to
get that and
i think at that moment he realizes that
there's too much
going on inside his head to
just keep
going the way he's going and he makes a
choice
whether it's the right choice or not he
makes a choice to do something and to
try and take care of himself and i think
that's a hard choice for anyone to make
i was proud of him that he decided to
focus on getting better i hope he finds
a little bit of peace i hope he finds
peace too but at the same time i'm
feeling very selfish as a fan i'm like
if we get a third season of lock and key
what does this mean for tyler like what
do you think connor i'm a little uh uh
biased because we've actually shot
season three so i know
but i can i can't i can answer
hypothetically my dream version of it
was that it was like uh you know he
spent all season road tripping it's like
a thelma louise the magic will always
pull you back i think in one way or
another and it might it might be
surprising the ways that it happens but
i think
tyler realizes
that he needs to confront the source of
what's happening and why he's feeling
the way he is um and that's in season
two as well part of being becoming an
adult is taking responsibility for your
actions and for the way you feel and for
the people you care about um so i think
that's really tyler's journey in the
show entirely i can't move on from
things that still make no sense to me
darby watching nina this season just
kind of broke my heart because all she
wanted to do was just understand what
was happening in her own house
exactly that's all she's wanted but
watching bodie take her inside her own
head and getting to live out those happy
memories was just so amazing what was
your reaction when you found out the
inside of her head is like the ultimate
antique shop oh it seemed very fitting
for nina seeing that every other scene
she is
working on stained glass window or
reupholstering an antique chair i was
secretly thinking if that head doesn't
have some stained glass in it then i
don't know that i know who this
character is no i'm just kidding
visually i also love the way um the
location they chose and
how
um the directors shot that mark chondre
shot that sequence um in that antique
store it was really beautiful so
um it seemed very fitting for nina's you
would tell me wouldn't you if there was
something going on you guys left us on a
little bit of an ominous cliffhanger
bodhi maybe used the memory key on his
mom what do you think and what can you
tease about what could come next in
season three maybe i mean let me tell
you i sure hope that he does because um
nina might just start drinking if
you know she doesn't get some answers
i mean she's like i remembered it once
where's the gym which season two twist
surprised you guys the most i know you
filmed it a while ago but thinking back
to when you were reading the scripts
conor which one really shocked you was
it jackie's death i mean at the end of
season two
jackie dies um
scott leaves
um
dodge
dies eden dies
you know a lot of characters that are
major characters of the show in the
season especially and also just
personally a lot of people who were a
big part of our experience shooting
suddenly left
so i wasn't expecting our show to be so
um
so merciless it's time to finish
what i started you gotta give me a
little tiny tease the fans have finished
binging season two they're gonna want
more connor what teas can you give me
season two was even bigger than season
one and season three is so much bigger
than all of them
it's like season one and season two put
in a blender uh and then a lot more
added season three has um
has a lot going on so i'm excited for
people to be taking on that very very
very bumpy roller coaster darby anything
you wanna yeah i would agree i i'd say
season three you can hardly catch your
breath
it's really non-stop and i agree with
what connor said it's it's uh
amped up even more
the evil forces behind the black door if
you think that dodge being dodge or
dodge being gabe was malicious the evil
and the enemy is captain frederick
gooding is even more merciless than
season we wanted to so it's it's um
quite gripping it's up to us now
this has to end